[Musica]
allora buon pomeriggio a tutti prima di
tutto e grazie per la presentazione e io
comincio a parlarvi di sanità
come avrete capito è un ambito di cui mi
occupo professionalmente nel campo dei
sistemi digitali quindi potete
immaginare quante potenzialità di
innovazione di superamento di alcuni
limiti ci possono essere applicando
queste tecnologie per la sanità in
sanità è molto diffuso ormai la
digitalizzazione dei processi delle
attività si parla di un sacco di
tecnologie molto interessanti
all'interno sia delle aziende sanitarie
che degli ospedali con grandi
potenzialità in chirurgia per la
gestione delle terapie intelligenza
artificiale per fare diagnosi che chi
più ne ha più ne metta
in realtà vediamo se riesco a mandare se
mi mandate avanti
in realtà però vorrei uscire
dall'ospedale non mi interessa tanto
parlarvi di ospedale come
centro di queste di questo tema della
cura dell'assistenza alle persone
sto pensando invece a quello che succede
a casa quello che succede a persone che
si confrontano con casistiche che sono
molto diffuse di cui sicuramente chiede
la mia generazione ci si può riconoscere
io sono del 1967
lascio il computo e abbiamo una
situazione in cui per fare un esempio
qui abbiamo chiamiamo da alberto che ha
casa a una situazione di cronicità non
può vivere in modo molto semplice da
solo e con i suoi 82 anni a una serie di
problemi da gestire e sua figlia lucia
cosa fa corre essenzialmente si muove
tra mille servizi tra dialogo col medico
di medicina generale la necessità di
capire cosa deve fare se deve attivare
un assistenza a domicilio se deve
parlare con una cooperativa di
infermieri sul territorio oppure come
vedremo ci sono numeri importanti
alla fine fa il colloquio una badante
per vedere di risolvere un po il
problema non sapendo bene che il
contratto deve fare chi l'aiuta come
farà eccetera eccetera eccetera
in mezzo a questo poi deve chiedere
permessi al lavoro deve accompagnarlo a
fare degli esami e poi ci sarebbe anche
la sua famiglia incidentalmente quindi
lucia si deve porre il problema di dare
una mano andare a scuola sentire i
professori eccetera eccetera
quindi la domanda è
alberto ha bisogno di aiuto e chi dà una
mano a lucia
perché vedete io l'ho rappresentata più
volte no è veramente al teletrasporto e
perché parlo di questa cosa parlando di
salute di sanità perché il il punto
nodale è che lucia e la sua famiglia il
suo padre hanno bisogno di assistenza di
lungo termine che non è l'assistenza che
ci dall'ospedale hanno bisogno di un
punto di contatto di coordinare dei
servizi perché l'assistenza di lungo
termine si basa sul fatto di avere
servizi coordinati e articolati che
consentano di migliorare la qualità
della vita delle persone di dare
autonomia di consentire un percorso di
quanto meno mantenimento di una certa
autonomia
vi porto quattro numeri significativi
che secondo me pero fanno riflettere
prima di tutto di persone e le chiamano
over 65 in italia che soffrono del
problema della non autosufficienza e
quindi avrebbero bisogno di questi
servizi sono circa 3 milioni
questi sono dati degli ultimi che ho
recuperato quindi possiamo stimare che
siano attorno a 3 milioni
se facciamo un calcolo approssimativo di
questi tre milioni ciascuno cia intorno
ad un paio di congiunti facendo una
stima un po spannometrica come avevamo
dire io
questo vuol dire che fate le dovute
moltiplicazioni questo fenomeno
interpella circa un sesto della
popolazione italiana
sono numeri importanti sono tanti quanto
meno 9 milioni di persone
i dipendenti del servizio sanitario
nazionale sul territorio italiano sono
circa 600 mila le badanti hanno sforato
il tetto del milione
pensate quindi cosa voglia dire in
questi termini la risposta dei servizi
nei confronti di chi ha questi problemi
allora il punto è dire quali sono i
limiti del nostro sistema che comporta
quali sono i limiti che comportano
questo tipo di frammentarietà di
difficoltà nell offrire dei servizi di
questo genere e soprattutto dare
risposte al fabbisogno di queste
famiglie
notate che quali sono i limiti forti c'è
sicuramente un limite di risorse le
risorse non sono infinite per il
servizio sanitario nazionale che
ricordiamoci il nostro servizio
sanitario è uno dei migliori al mondo e
non è una critica verso il servizio
sanitario è però le risorse non sono
infinite quindi non si può arrivare
dappertutto
la comunicazione tra i vari servizi è
sempre piuttosto complessa perché ci
sono competenze del comune ci sono
competenze dell'azienda sanitaria ci
sono dati frammentari quindi
sostanzialmente chi coordina questi
servizi
magari avendo sullo sfondo anche la
magari la possibilità di avere un po di
welfare aziendale e non sarebbe male è
di fatto la persona il familiare e
quindi si trova a gestire tutto questo
insieme di servizi magari non
conoscendoli con scarse informazioni e
difficoltà di gestione come amo dire di
fatto lucia e l'imbottitura di un
sandwich si trova generazione semplice
proprio titolo di un articolo che ho
fatto abbastanza discutere che riguarda
il fatto di avere essere schiacciata
come l'imbottitura tra la gestione di
suo padre e la gestione della propria
famiglia del proprio lavoro
essere schiacciato da qui dentro due
fette di pane
non credo faccia piacere a nessuno
quindi il punto è che cosa si potrebbe
fare considerando i limiti del sistema
che cosa si può fare perché questi
limiti ci sono e non necessariamente
dobbiamo pensare di pestarsi la testa
contro dobbiamo ipotizzare delle
soluzioni che possano sfruttando
possibilmente anche delle tecnologie che
sono mature disponibili di superare
questi limiti e quindi espanderli questi
servizi
diamo ce la faccio è mandare avanti
allora l'idea che mi sono fatto in
questi anni
parlando e discutendo con molte persone
che si occupano anche di ricerca in modo
particolare su questi temi è che di
fatto abbiamo bisogno di un bel l'uovo
al tegamino digitale questo lo vedo come
il fatto di avere nel tuorlo la
conoscenza il fatto di avere la capacità
di gestire servizi e sulla periferia
slip per computer
noi informatici e non ha dovuto spegnere
e riaccendere quello sarebbe stato tipi
e capita anche in sanità quello che
dicevo è che c'è la periferia connessa
quei servizi avere la conoscenza e la
capacità di gestione e soprattutto poter
coordinare le attività secondo percorsi
di gestione importanti e finalizzati e
personalizzati alla necessità delle
persone
questo a livello tecnologico lo
conosciamo non sto dicendo delle cose se
pensate quante volte avete ceduto a
strumenti ma piattaforme come sarebbe
più corretto dire tipo tripadvisor
booking huber
di fatto qualcuno di voi avrà
sicuramente avuto usufruito di questi
servizi è queste tecnologie che si
basano su intelligenza artificiale su
disponibilità di sensori di parecchie
soluzioni che sono veramente di mercato
ci permettono di organizzare e dico
permettono al presente perché non sto
dicendo di cose su cui bisogna fare
tanti passi oltre di coordinare questi
servizi metterli ha fatto il comune
consentire a una famiglia di avere delle
risposte
ovviamente come può diventare questo
percorso sfruttando questo tipo di
tecnologie di fatto non sto dicendo che
il percorso vada a semplificarsi in modo
radicale perché chiaramente la
preoccupazione per alberto lucia se
l'avrà sempre non è che semplifichiamo
le cose o le banalizziamo
però possiamo fornire tutta una serie di
servizi coordinati sgravando la famiglia
e la persona da questa necessità di
reperire i servizi sul territorio e
coordinarli la cosa importante che
possiamo produrre fiducia all'interno di
questa piattaforma nei confronti dei
servizi e garantire un ritorno
importante verso le famiglie in termini
di salvaguardia del proprio tempo e
possibilità di gestire dei problemi che
diversamente sarebbe estremamente
complessi
la domanda è chi le fa queste cose e ci
sono diversi enti che nell'ambito per
esempio privato stanno iniziando a fare
questi diciamo esperimenti mettere sul
mercato delle piattaforme di questo
genere anche il pubblico ci si sta
affacciando pian piano qual è il tema
che io vorrei sottolineare oggi e che
soprattutto ci vuole consapevolezza da
parte dell'utenza
perché in qualche modo dobbiamo crearla
una domanda di questi servizi di questa
possibilità di avere risposte perché in
primo luogo dobbiamo aspettarci di poter
accedere a dei servizi di assistenza
sanitaria a domicilio con queste
modalità
questo è molto importante perché come è
importante che cresca la sensibilità e
la creazione di queste piattaforme dal
punto di vista dell'offerta che noi
troveremo dovremo anche diventare
consapevoli della possibilità di
utilizzare questi servizi
questo è molto importante e io credo che
possa essere una risposta effettiva quei
numeri che secondo me sono positivi
perché viviamo di più però complicati da
gestire nel prossimo futuro quindi
volevo concludere con un osservazione
specifica sul tema dell'innovazione e
soprattutto in questi ambiti
se me la mandate avanti ecco vedete la
famiglia ora riunita e
il il punto è che da utenti come da
produttori di questi servizi non
dobbiamo porci il problema di essere in
qualche modo sempre orientati
correttamente nella progettazione delle
cose nell'inventare le cose sempre
cogliendo nel segno ogni volta che
facciamo un esperimento
la cosa importante dobbiamo affacciarsi
a questo tipo di soluzioni di servizi
sapendo come io cito sempre un verso di
una canzone di paolo conte che dice
bisogna saper sbagliare da
professionisti quindi andare in una
direzione che ci permetta di offrire a
questa famiglia una piattaforma in cui
possano avere fiducia trovare risposte
ai propri fabbisogni e soprattutto
garantire qualità della vita alle
persone con questo credo aveva detto
tutto
[Musica]
[Applauso]